Here is a simple example of a representation. It is a decomposition of a single
component, which is called here, the component. The component involves a,
two ports: one for dealing with easy requests, and one for dealing with hard
requests. And then, there's the representation, which describes the details.
In a sub-system, called details that has two components.
One fast but dumb component and second a slow but
smart component. The binding section then pastes these two levels together.
Easy requests are mapped to the fast but dumb component port P and
hardRequests to the slowButSmartComponent also called Port P. Hence we
now have the same system described at two different levels of abstraction,
the lower one allowing us to go into the more details than the upper one.